Black Clover just took a deadly turn as
the black Bulls sacrifice everything for
asta's return this is bloody and brutal
and also kind of romantic but like you
know Romeo and Juliet Way and this could
be the beginning of a new era the rise
of a new and much darker Asta a dark
wizard King so let's talk about it you
guys know how this works if you enjoy my
Black Clover videos and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it really helps me
out with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this the video do you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications we are pushing for
2 million subscribers here on the
channel so let's get it done finally
this video will contain Black Clover
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now just a
quick recap app in the previous chapter
we got to see seki and that's the only
thing that matters from that chapter
period all right I guess there was some
pretty important stuff there at the end
of the chapter we saw a bunch of the
black Bulls along with the Black Bull
base in Mecca form heading out to
confront the Paladin damnatio Kira and
the guardian angels under his command
the black Bulls were forced to undertake
this massive risk because the amnesio is
trying to stop the ritual that would
summon Asta back from Hino country
funeral and the most powerful witches in
the world are required to stay behind
and conduct the ritual so that means
that the rest of the black Bulls who are
not involved with the ritual directly
have to step up and face off against
damnatio the latest chapter begins with
a brief flashback to before the black
Bulls went out to confront themnation
with the witch Queen telling everyone
that the Clover Kingdom capital is in
serious danger and that Asta is
desperately needed in order to turn
things around knocked adds that the the
fact that Lucius was so quick to send
someone to stop the ritual means that
Asta must be vital in this situation and
this only makes their current mission to
bring us to back even more important and
even more urgent basically there is no
way that Lucius will lose unless the
doors of Destiny are opened and Asta
returns to the Clover Kingdom as soon as
possible because of this the black bulls
have to do everything in their power to
buy time for the ritual to be completed
and as this chapter revealed the black
Bulls are indeed willing to make extreme
sacrifices in order to keep damnatio
away from the ritual perhaps even the
ultimate sacrifice back in the present
the black Bulls are on the battlefield
and they are doing their best to counter
the power of themnatio's scale dominate
but despite the best efforts of Henry
Gordon and the others damnnatio simply
uses his holy sword to smash apart the
blackballs base in a single attack
completely crushing the entire building
and injuring Henry and Gordon along the
way damnatio then gets all philosophical
and says that scales without a blade are
meaningless just like a blade without
scales is merely violence order comes
about when a just Arbiter uses a
combination of scales and the blade and
Amnesia believes himself to be that just
Arbiter the guardian angels then launch
energy beams at the black Bulls but even
though multiple black Bulls are injured
they also manage to do some damage to
the angels we see luck smashing one of
them to pieces and we see all the black
bulls fighting fiercely without much
regard for their own well-being in fact
the attack is so bold and determined
that several of the black Bulls
including knocked and Zora managed to
get up close and personal to themnetio
himself which genuinely surprises him
dementia is surprised because the black
Bulls are launching a borderline
self-deleting assault right at him and
he didn't expect them to be this willing
to sacrifice themselves in the face of
overwhelm danger the black bulls have
been taking the kind of damage that
should have knocked him out of the
battle already and yet they are still
advancing and still fighting as
ruthlessly as ever damnatio then finally
realizes what's really going on the
black Bulls are able to take on so much
damage because gray is using her
overpowered Transformation Magic to heal
them just like she healed gauche after
he suffered a mortal wound in the battle
against Dante only this time gosh is
using his mirror magic to make a bunch
of copies of gray so now every black
bull has a great copy behind them at all
times on the battlefield and this copy
of gray is healing them in real time as
they attack it's actually really cool to
see gray using her healing powers again
in battle and it's especially great
seeing gray and gauche working together
we know that gray really likes gauche
and I definitely support this ship if
for no other reason than for little
Marie's sake anyway the nation realizes
that in order to counter this strategy
he has to find the real gray and he
quickly realizes that gray is hiding in
the form of one of charmy's cooking
sheep thingies damnatio proceeds to
attack the real gray with his extremely
overpowered sword but gosh gets in
between gray and the blade in an attempt
to protect her with his body
unfortunately this doesn't seem to work
and the blade appears to go all the way
through gauche and then through gray as
well severely wounding both of them I
would say fatally wounding both of them
but this is Black Clover so we gotta be
realistic back at the side of the ritual
Vanessa finral and the others are trying
to open the portal as soon as possible
but it's still not ready not yet they
need to go faster as we see the
seemingly dead bodies of gauche and gray
lying beside each other and as the
amnesio declares that this fight is over
we get a brief look at Ryu and Asta back
in Hino country hosta sees that Ryu
suddenly has a grave and worried Express
question on his face and Asta
immediately begins to sweat he doesn't
know what exactly just happened but he
sees that it isn't good and yet despite
the tragedy that just occurred before
their very eyes the black Bulls are not
done yet socray uses ceiling magic to
presumably seal gray and gauche away in
order to prevent them from dying from
their injuries we know she can use her
ceiling magic for the purposes of
healing and Recovery she can seal away
injuries and even reconnect limbs so as
I said this is Black Clover don't assume
that anyone is actually dead yet as the
rest of the black Bulls refuse to stand
down despite being injured and as they
prepare to continue fighting against
overwhelming odds this chapter comes to
an end and man this is definitely a dark
and intense chapter and the stakes have
never been higher we are told that
without asta's immediate return to the
Clover Kingdom everything will be
destroyed Lucius will win and all of us
as friends fans are likely going to die
in fact it appears that two of his
fellow black bulls have died already
normally this would cause a lot of
tension among the fan base as we wait to
see what happens in the next chapter but
we've already seen so many apparent
deaths in Black Clover that ended up not
being death in the end so I just can't
convince myself that gray and gauche are
actually in danger don't get me wrong I
think that having one or more black
bulls die during this Arc would be
extremely impactful and it would have a
massive effect on Austin's entire
character if someone really close to him
were to die while he was away in Hino
country he would feel terrible about not
being able to be there to protect his
friends and he would also feel extremely
angry at Lucius and the villains for
what they've done something like this
might even turn him into a darker
character overall someone who is more
willing to be ruthless and merciless
towards villains in the future because
he doesn't want to give them the chance
to hurt someone close to him ever again
if Asta eventually becomes the wizard
King it would be fascinating to see how
he would act if he had the experience of
losing close friends and comrades at the
hands of the villains would the way he
acts in his position as wizard King be
impacted by this trauma would he maybe
be more authoritarian because he wants
to make sure that this never happens
again would he be more willing to hunt
down and straight up eliminate villains
would he become a different person from
the US that we know and love or what
asta's character turned so dark that he
no longer wants to be the wizard King at
all what if he leaves the position of
wizard King to yuno while he becomes a
Dark Avenger traveling around the world
and hunting down villains before they
have a chance to hurt an innocent person
these dark Austin scenarios would be
fascinating to explore but I'll be the
first to admit that these are not very
likely Asta is just too pure of a
character and Tabata just doesn't seem
willing to kill off important characters
whose death would have a profound impact
on Asta what do you guys think are gray
and gauche really about to pull a Romeo
and the Juliet or are they going to
survive is anyone else close to Asta in
danger of dying could a darker version
of Asta be a possibility in the future
or are we just looking at uh they all
lived happily ever after type of ending
don't forget to give me your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this Black Clover video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people watching this
video right now who are not subscribed
to the channel do me a big favor and
subscribe right now and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it helps me out a
lot here with the channel finally you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys